[Music]
hey what's up guys Samuel Leeds here on
this video we wanted to give a little
bit of a behind-the-scenes show of what
happens with our training business
because we're selling out venues your
houses here venues all the time now
every month we've got a lot of
infrastructure so we need admin people
we need people on the computers many
people doing customer service so I
decided rather than interviewing people
and asking to see their CVS and dig over
through the normal boring way instead I
would do it as an event where we open up
the doors in our office where people can
come and they can pitch themselves as a
new member of the team so we've got
about 30 people come in so let's see
what happens
yeah economies I'm gonna get the lowdown
about our company what we're looking for
we're looking for kind of roles that are
available and also a vision foundation
we have we have here a mission statement
since I like budget at tipo de Bona and
this is coming up on our first wall
we're going to give you guys an
opportunity to to just stand up and just
kind of sight it in maybe 60 seconds
what n is if you're wanting to do within
our company and also why you think you'd
make a really good employer removal
staff you've probably done with this
already is such a passionate images
that's the people were looking for an
amazing boss an amazing team and every
day we hear our mission see people doing
well lunchtime so it's not touch the job
you want to work hard to be sold into it
and together we are phenomenal team that
deliver greatness to the people who make
a big one for everything you need we're
helping people were giving back and it's
that mentalities that
okay and this is a team code of honor
treat others as you would want to be
treated
never say that can't be done but rather
how can it be done never abandon a
teammate in need never contradict or
undermine of team mate unless done
privately celebrate all wins and
regularly praise others everybody sells
and owns our a mission mission the
mission comes first do whatever it takes
never gossip if you wouldn't see it to
the face don't see it at all do what you
say see what you mean be as you seem
I'll that's my favorite always take full
responsibility for any problems and
never blame others
so just brief introduction it may be a
little bit about yourself what you do
and what value you bring to the team
[Music]
and also people
on this occasion
our team of decided and not for now that
doesn't mean our relationships over
so please do stay in contact with us we
still the company that's thriving still
the company's going both places so do
just watch out for anything in the
future you given you time to some people
and to speak and thank you for that
really appreciated well I guess we could
say to around three right now what we're
going to do we can speak to two groups
customer service sales we're gonna set
you a challenge a group challenge and
then we're going to we're gonna we're
gonna fill down the best of you we're
gonna do want to want interviews and
then BOOM so Samuel is just sent people
off into three different groups we've
got the sales guys who are all working
on selling the book but the marketing
guys who are trying to figure out the
best marketing strategy how they're
gonna market the book and although the
admin guys writing up a brief summary of
the book and what's great about this
task is only got 15 minutes so it's very
very limited on time and be very
interesting to see what they come up
with because normally what they come
over is what they know it's what they
get and maybe bring to the table
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
under the problem you can call me mr.
problem in order to get the bull details
while securing what properties
either Jess Isaac and so then so we
brought you through to tell you you are
a very strange day but it's kept me on
my toes all those is what I liked that
kind of gave me the essence of the
company as well and I'm going to say
that last bit where we have to leave the
room
there's definitely special I thought I
was going home and I'm still here so a
lot of people for interviews I know I'm
Senate's and when I was younger I used
to do it I used to just revise I think
at the end of the day if you actually
eat so it's not just about so if you're
pretending to be somebody else look you
know my manager by she's got
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you for giving me this opportunity
and I'm excited to be working with you
all and it's been an eventful day today
so I think it's been a pretty good day
we've taken we've got interviews going
on right here one-on-one interviews now
we've taken on four new members of the
team to the whole new staff members
anything you went really well
awesome and also if you would like to
apply to have a full-time position at
Samuel ins office then go to the website
property - investors coder UK and at the
bottom of the website and there should
be somewhere a little vacancies box so
hope to see you soon stay tuned good job
guys
you